the UK government has this morning
unveiled a national semiconductor
strategy that will soon invest up to 1
billion pounds over the next decade the
aim will be to boost the UK's strengths
in design and research and development
and in so-called compound semiconductors
that semiconductor material composed of
two or more elements it's also aimed at
supporting the UK's domestic ship
industry at a time when Chinese
aggression towards Taiwan is
highlighting the risks in the global
semiconductor supply chain or join me
now Scott White is co-founder and
executive director of strategic
initiatives and pragmatic semiconductor
Scott welcomed you I mean this
initiative has been in the uh pipeline
for two years what's kept it
I think it's it's a complex challenge I
think for the UK of figuring out where
does it fit into things you know we
can't really take exactly the same
approach that the US and EU have of
saying we're going to spend tens of
billions of dollars Euros pounds on
investing in bringing Advanced silicon
node manufacturing into the UK it just
would not actually be a cost-effective
thing to do in the UK and certainly
wouldn't be sustainable in the long term
so ultimately would be uh would be a
waste of money so I think there's been a
lot of effort focused on actually where
does the UK have strengths where can it
really play to those how does it develop
those in the best way and then in
parallel with that uh how does the UK
work with its International allies to
ensure that it has appropriate security
supply across broader technologies that
they can't plan
well one of those strengths is compound
semiconductors for the uninitiated what
what are those
so as you describe compound
semiconductors are uh basically
semiconductors that have more than one
element from the periodic table perhaps
to to simplify it even more it tends to
be used as a catch-all term for anything
that is non-silicon semiconductor
materials so most of our semiconductor
devices today are in the form of silicon
chips but actually there are a number of
other materials that can create
semiconductor devices that have better
or different characteristics so as an
example we make semiconductor devices
that are extremely thin and flexible so
they look I'd like that rather than
being rigid chips
and that means that they can be embedded
in a wider variety of things
fantastic what was that term made of the
uh item you just held up
uh so we used what's called thin film
thin film semiconductor materials
they're basically based on metal oxides
uh but essentially they allow us to do
the equivalent kind of functionality to
a silicon chip but at about 10 times
lower cost and with that unique form
factor so in the context of what the UK
is trying to solve in terms of Supply
chains we can actually replace silicon
chips in a number of those critical
applications that have been holding up
uh manufacturing of other key products
in the industry but they can also enable
you new use cases such as embedding
Electronics into packaging for
fast-moving consumer goods everything
you buy in the supermarket could have a
unique identity that can be tracked to
allow better supply chain traceability
and even things like improving the
recycling and reuse of packaging at end
of life and how did the UK come to have
a a lead in compounds in this way
the UK has always had a strong
um R D
um focus in semiconductors if you go
back 20 years or so we were actually did
also have a significant position in
Silicon although that is for a variety
of reasons generally moved out to the
Far East but I think that underlying r d
capability uh based in in many respects
on our world-leading universities and
the the skills and talent that we've
built as a result of that historical uh
position in Silicon that has led us to
be able to develop these new
capabilities and the challenge now
really is how do we make sure that as we
develop those into a larger scale that
we ensure the value of that is retained
in the UK we've talked a lot in the past
about the way China has cornered the
market in certain commodities for
example so-called rare earth metals is
there a danger that some of the elements
involved in these compound
semiconductors again China will have
will have cornered the market in them
there's certainly uh there's certainly
challenges in many semiconductor
materials around the the sources of
supply and so ensuring that it's not
just about having one piece of the
puzzle but the the we look across the
entire supply chain of what's needed I
think that's also though an area for
Innovation where some of these newer
Advanced material Technologies can get
around the challenges of some of the
critical material supply constraints of
existing conventional semiconductor
Manufacturing
Scott we've got to leave it there I'm
afraid it's good to see you again sir
thank you thank you
our Nationwide Building Society is to
hand 340 million pounds to members with
whom it has its deepest relationships
the UK's second biggest mortgage lender
will pay 100 pounds next month to
members who hold both a qualifying
current account and a qualifying savings
or mortgage account well the news came
as Nationwide reported a pre-tax profit
of 2.2 billion pounds for the year to
the 4th of April that was up from 1.6
billion pounds in the same period a year
earlier and came despite Nationwide
reducing its share of gross mortgage
lending during the year it share of the
overall mortgage Market meanwhile fell
from 12.4 to 12.2 percent will joining
me now is the chief executive of
Nationwide Debbie Crosby Debbie welcome
to you how many people will qualify
roughly for this payout
good morning Ian roughly 300 um 3.4
million of our members very good I mean
this is obviously great publicity uh for
you but I mean the cynical old
journalist in me uh Debbie wonders
whether this is a recognition that
you've got too much capital on your
balance sheet and this is a neat way of
handing some of it back
while in all of our profits because
we're a mutual are retained for the
benefit of our members so what we're
doing is we're thinking about the right
ways to return the best value and in
addition to the Fatal share payment that
we've announced we've also announced a
fair share bond which pays 4.5
4.75 which is available to 60 million
members and that would also be on top of
the billion pounds in financial benefit
we've already delivered this year so
it's all about returning value because
the profit stay for our members the
fairer share bond is paying four and
three quarter percent over two years you
have to have your money tied up for that
period of time
yes you do
right looking at the results then uh
impairments came in at 126 million
pounds I think what were the kind of
loans on which you've you've been making
impairments most
yeah so our payments are more or less
black the large by a lot the large
majority of our loans are our mortgages
and our books and actually they've been
performing well and despite a lot of the
narrative externally we've seen
um very stable arrears and very
comfortable with that position
I think at the uh tail end of last year
you were predicting that house prices
would remain more or less static for the
next 12 months is that still your your
base case
so our base cases
um but we still expect some minor
adjustments downwards we began to see
stabilization actually in our last house
pricing index we saw a very small rise
for me what that shows is early signs of
stability stabilization but I would say
that it's going to remain volatile in
the coming months so we are cautiously
optimistic
obviously uh you let your share of gross
mortgage lending slip last year from
your traditional share what was the
thinking there
yeah well it's a very small
um reduction and really what we saw
there is that um we saw a lot of
dislocation in the mortgage market and
it was a very very
um competitive market and we focused
mainly on our existing members
um we have got great retention we've
managed to retain around 80 percent of
our existing customers and therefore we
felt it was better to focus on providing
them the best value rates but we still
supported one in seven first-time buyers
and we're still very optimistic that
we're beginning to see some signs of
recovery in the mortgage markets on
early signs of recovery but we still
aren't back to where we were a
pre-pandemic
what about buy to let mortgages
obviously uh there are a lot of amateur
landlords who are giving up the ghost
and leaving the market what sort of
demand are you seeing for buy to let
mortgages right now
so buy to let demand has fallen and you
are aware Ian that it's challenging for
uh landlords there is a number of
um difficult issues for them at the
moment Rising mortgage rates have meant
the profitability in the buy to let
Market is more challenged and we think
first-time buyers and we we think that
um
landlords are a really important part of
the private rental market and will
continue to support them but right now
we understand that it is difficult for
them
but uh is that a share of the market
that potentially you're looking to grow
or you you're basically keeping share
where it is right now
we we would we've seen a reduction in
the overall market so our share of flow
we will maintain but as I say the market
is quite considerably down this year
what about the savings Market uh We've
we've talked about the new Bond that uh
you've you've launched today but I mean
more broadly speaking a lot of
Institutions are being accused of of not
passing on the full extent of the bank
of England's interest rate Rises over
the last 15 months or so what proportion
of rate hikes have you roughly been able
to pass on
so we passed through about 55 which is
65 more than the average of the High
Street lenders so you know we are in
quite a different position to a number
of the High Street lenders and actually
what you'll see in our results is we've
got a really strong deposit performance
our deposits grew overall in the year by
over 9 billion actually 6 billion of
that was in the second half of the year
um so we are we are seeing very strong
performance and and I would also say
that what's working really well for us
is most of our a lot of our two-thirds
of our online of our savings fixed rate
bonds are being opened in our branches
40 of our eyes as this year have been
opened in our branches so not only are
our competitive rates driving really
strong flows
um also the fact that we can offer
people the opportunity to come in sit
with our colleagues in the branches and
have um a conversation is working
incredibly well for us
that's very interesting because
obviously a lot of your competitors
there's a closing branches right now I
mean you've actually been actively
opening them in some locations
well we are really committed to a branch
Network we think it's an important part
of what we do and you know given we're a
mutual we can make these choices and
it's another way that we return value to
our members and our members have told us
that um whilst um digital is important
for convenience they also want when it's
a complicated issue or when they want to
maybe have a conversation about
something that's more more difficult for
them they do want the opportunity to
come in and that's not just um older
people it's also younger people that
we've found when the issue is complex
they want to be able to sit down and
have a conversation with someone that
they can trust
and just going back to this point on
savings at the moment what sort of
behavior are you seeing among your your
savings customers right now are they
changing the duration of which they're
tying up their money
what we're seeing Ian is that a number
of people who historically held balances
in their current accounts are being much
more focused on the rates so we're
seeing a real shift from balances being
held in current accounts and instant
access accounts into longer term fixed
rate bones isas Etc so we're definitely
seeing that shift we've seen some cases
Debbie in the recent past of where where
savings products have been launched on
the market and they prove so popular
that uh the the institution involved has
had to close them to uh to new customers
very very quickly I mean if you get
trampled in the rush for this new Bond
will you be forced to shut the doors on
it
so first of all that new bond is only
available to our existing members and
that's really important because we want
to make sure that we give the best rates
to the people who are already part of
the building Society we hope that it
attracts new members of course in the
future
um but that particular bond is only for
our existing customers but we thought
very hard about how we are ready for
what I do think will be a very busy
period for us and we've also said that
we will only make the bonds available
for a fixed period of time and we'll
review how busy we are and decide how
long we keep that product on sale but
you can open it online you can telephone
us and we're prepared to open it or we'd
be delighted to see you in one of our
branches to open it yeah we're looking
forward to being busy in do you worry
about competition from National savings
I mean obviously they've been mandated
by the government to bring in more money
they've raised their rates on a lot of
products including premium bonds
so we pay attention to all of our
competition and what we think we offer
Great Value and as a mutual as well as
offering Great Value we hope that people
recognize that we can also give back to
society this year and we've been able to
donate as we have in previous years one
percent of our profits and um you know
for this year that amount
um we've donated just under 10 million
pounds the good good quality causes so
we hope that that really means something
to people and it's one of the reasons
that they would choose to put their
deposits with Nationwide as well as
their rates and great service indeed
it's a busy day for your results day we
do appreciate you spending the time to
speak to us thanks Debbie
some other business news stories for you
now and Walt Disney has scrap plans for
two major investments in Florida under
which more than 2 000 california-based
employees would have relocated to a new
900 million dollar campus in the state
the move follows a row with the Florida
governor Ron DeSantis who wants to strip
Disney of the right to essentially run
Reedy Creek which is a special tax
District nor Orlando which is home to
Walt Disney World and a number of the
company's hotels the move comes after
Disney spoke out against the Florida
education bill which limited classroom
discussion of gender and sexuality
shares of Smith's group Rose by one
percent this morning after the ftse 100
engineering and Industrial technology
specialist raised its annual sales
forecast for the third time in five
months Smith's which is best known for
its airport security scanners but which
also supplies couplings and bearings to
the oil and gas industry and electronic
components for the Aerospace and defense
sectors said it now expects sales growth
to come in at around 10 percent this
year the company which had previously
predicted sales growth of around eight
percent said it continued to see strong
growth in most of its end markets
the Irish drinks Group which owns Brands
including tenants lager and Bulma cider
has replaced its chief executive
following the botched systems upgrade
CNC group whose other brands include
Magnus cider said David Ford had stepped
down after a systems upgrade at Matthew
Clark and bibendum its drinks
distribution businesses had taken longer
than expected it said disruptions caused
by the delayed upgrade would result in a
one-off hits a profit of around 25
million euros well CNC group has
appointed role friendly the former chief
executive of the pub operator Marstons
to oversee the transition to a new chief
executive the shares are currently off
by some 17 percent
and the parent of company of the hotter
shoes brand has put itself up for sale
Unbound Group which targets the over 55
year old customer demographic said it
had recently been holding talks with its
advisors and banks with a view to
raising more funds either by sale of new
shares or by extending its borrowing
facilities but it's said that as part of
that process it had also decided to
initiate a formal review of strategic
options available to it including a
formal sale process the shares are
currently down by 20 percent
[Music]
well another positive finish on Wall
Street last night was followed by mixed
trading for equities overnight you can
see the picture in the Asia Pacific
region both the Hong Kong and Shanghai
markets fell amid concerns over the
Chinese economy but look at the top
left-hand Corner the Nikkei in Tokyo
continued on its recent blistering run
and it's today hit its highest level
since August 1990. that was a month I
started working in the city actually in
Europe equities are also going into the
weekend on an upbeat note here's the
current picture all of the main
Continental European markets in positive
territory right now talking points
include Auto Grill the Italian Motorway
and Airport Services Group is aired by
some three and a half percent in Milan
as they take over draws ever closer well
here in London the foot to 100 it's also
in positive territory right now upper
just under half of one percent in a
broad-based rally led by The Mining and
energy heavyweights among the gainers in
the ftse this morning while flutter
entertainment is among the main one
that's ahead by nearly 2 present a lot
of positive broker commentary about that
company recently on the downside
Burberry is off another three percent
that's on the back of its results
yesterday outside the footsie not a
great deal of uh corporate talking
points to get into today but Titan
Holdings is down by some 12 right now
after Rising losses forced the windows
and ventilation system specialist to cut
its dividend on the foreign exchange
markets or the main talking point is
that the Chinese Renminbi has fallen to
a five-month low against the US dollar
that's for Sterling well that's more or
less unchanged against the Greenback
it's down by a tenth of one percent
against the Euro The single currency
meanwhile is up by a fifth of one
percent against the dollar as for the
oil price well that is actually on
course right now for his first weekly
gain in five had a good week a good
session a couple of days ago Ballard
Brent crude will currently set you back
76.26 a barrel that is up a little over
half of one percent will joining me this
morning is Neil Wilson Chief Market
Analyst at finaldo Neil good to see you
this morning good start with Japan I
mean it's it's shooting the lights out
at the moment the knicker is I mean
Japanese equities are just far in favor
this year
um you know the bank of Japan you've got
to look at you know the global the
global situation here and you know the
feds raising rates ccp's raising rates
just about everyone is with Bank of
Japan's keeping things super loose there
so I think that's that's helping
um and that's helping to sort of get
those those risk assets a bit more a bit
more premium um I think also you know
investors have been looking for outside
of the US so us has been the big play
for 15 years big Tech although that's
fine that is finding bid this year again
um but you know investors have been
searching for for some you know some
better returns and Japan has just been
one of those markets that that's been
latched onto yeah I mean and Company
results have not been too bad either
coming out of Japan but yeah I mean the
the the economy in Japan seems to be
recovering pretty well
um you've got inflation actually he's up
at a 40 year high so the bank of Japan
is keeping things super loose despite
inflation at a 40 year hour that's the
the sort of core core inflation
um so it's trending above sort of three
to four percent and I think you know
that they're saying you know Bank of
Japan is saying that that's to do with
imported inflation
um but I think you know you've got to
look at the demand side as well so I
think the Japan's doing pretty well
Equity Market reflects that yeah I mean
it's it really does take me back I mean
the Nick a peaked I think it hit his
all-time high at the end of 1989 and
it's that was on the back of a bubble
it's been downhill for the last two
three decades really oh it's just
extraordinary yeah I mean it's that I
mean I I you've got a few a few years on
me there I think I was I was six when
when that was happening
um but uh the you know the you know
Japan's gone through this huge this
inflation this deflationary cycle for
the last sort of
um well 30 years really
um and that that has seen you know you
know it enjoyed a massive run-up that
was a massive bubble that was one of the
big old-time bubbles really
um and it's been trying to recover uh
recover ever since and really struggling
to get any inflation and inflation's you
know quite good A little bit of
inflation is quite good and and that's
what we're seeing there yeah I mean
elsewhere in the Asia pack region of
course yeah remember is uh sold off
today we've had issues in uh with some
of the other stock indices as well I
mean how seriously should people worry
about this yeah so I think you know
China there's a bit of doubt about China
there's obviously lots of problems uh
you know in terms of its Financial you
know the sort of financial system there
the property Market there
um you had Alibaba results maybe were a
little bit soft yesterday so that seems
to dented sentiment I mean the extent to
which we can trust any of the data is
obviously a little bit you know up in
there anyway but you know you had that
big China reopening story
um it's maybe not playing out entirely
as as maybe we thought and insert
certainly in terms of consumer demand
um but we are seeing for example oil
um or the man in China has hit a record
high 16 million barrels per day so there
are signs that China's recovering but
it's the extent to which the The
People's Bank of China ultimately always
comes back to the central banks uh you
know the extent to which it it sort of
helps float things and keep things going
and at the moment it's it's trying to
keep things quite buoyant um but there
are sort of fundamental fundamental
questions about the economy now okay I
know we've got the U.S debt ceiling
which is obviously the other big talking
but I've just been told actually that
we're about to see pictures from the G7
of uh the the world leaders Gathering
partly Joe Biden had a little stumble
apparently uh I mean I think we might
even be able to see it have a look at
that
oh there he goes yeah
I mean he's doing he's doing okay for an
eight-year-old I guess yeah but but I
mean
here's here are the live pictures now of
what's going on
they're gathering for the so-called
family photo there
no I mean do people will the dollar
start to react if we see things like
that happening more frequency I mean in
the old days you know Alan Greenspan
used to call from people used to worry
about his his health and the dollar
would react on that could you see that
happening with Biden I think it's priced
in I think it's well discounted by the
market already that that um you know
he's a an elderly gentleman and that
that sort of thing might happen I don't
think that
um there's a massive risk there you know
the dollar is moving on so many other
factors right now
um fed and obviously the global you know
the global economy
um I I think you know the the debt
ceiling obviously is is the key thing
that we're looking at at the moment it
looks like we're going to get something
over the line by by June the first
um and that that could result in some
further dollar strength should we see uh
bond yields pick up we think probably
there's gonna be a lot of issuance of
new bonds when when that debt ceiling
deal does get done that's going to send
yields higher that acts as a kind of
tightening in the market and so that
could push the dollar still further so
we think probably dollars further to run
now interesting I mean it is your base
case scenario now that there will be a
deal over the debt ceiling I I think
it's always a bit of a charade I don't I
don't think
um I mean you get to 2011 type scenario
um that can suck you know a lot of
um uh you know a lot of juice out of the
economy you get a sort of contraction of
maybe
even five percent uh GDP
um should the worst happen in terms of
the in terms of a shutdown
um I don't think you get a default you
know the US is not going to default I
don't see see how that how the US ever
defaults so
um I I think you know this is a charade
and we play it time and again and I
think we will get a deal and uh you
mentioned you think there's a bit more
upside for the dollar I mean if you take
if you look at it against Sterling for
example where does that go I think
you're in a kind of range at the moment
I think we're in a sort of range between
say 120 to 130 for Sterling dollar we're
tracking 124 and change at the moment
um I think you could see it you know
tests at 122 maybe
um but you know Sterling's catching some
upside too it's got some bid because of
you know the bank of England's going to
need to raise rates probably a bit more
the economy is doing better than we
thought
um but that's why I think probably when
this sort of tracking this kind of range
between about 120 and 130. all right now
I've got to leave it there always good
to see you thanks a lot
still to come here on inking live I'm
going to be speaking to the chief
executive of Ipswich town about why the
summer months are the busiest for those
controlling the footballing purse
strings stay with us
[Music]
when I was here last summer I said we
were really worried we'd had a 60
increase on the same period last year
Well since in that two-month period we
had further fire deaths and further fire
injuries all Associated to e-bikes any
scooters talk to me about these pictures
what what happened here well you can see
the picture here so the key point I'd
like your viewers to take away here is
you've gone from a normal morning in a
kitchen with somebody charging a
re-scooter to an unsurvivable
environment in a little under 12 seconds
that what looks like smoke is a totally
toxic Vapor Cloud it has just about
every nasty gas hydrogen cyanide in it
you can you can think of really toxic
and then you've got to Total flashover
conditions those Flames are over a
thousand degrees and it explodes and
puts particles all over your your room
and the other thing you're not quite
seeing on that footage is that that that
scooter has been charged in a communal
kitchen next to the communal Escape
Route for a number of bed sets so that
totally compromised the Escape Route
nobody's getting past that ideally
charge it outside charge it outside or
in a garage you're tricky it can and of
course they're quite a capital
investment you know these scooters are
probably one and a half thousand to two
thousand pounds e-bikes are over two
thousand pounds so you know a lot of
people won't want to charge it outside
because it's quite an investment if you
are having to charge it inside that is
not ideal I need to be clear about that
if you're having to charge it outside
don't compromise your Escape Route you
know have it somewhere where if it does
fail you can close the door and leave
immediately get your family you know and
let your neighbors get out call us out
and stay out we've had examples okay uh
you know around the corner in southwark
a foldable e-bike uh the the occupants
heard a hiss and a bang and it blew the
bedroom door off and they they explode
with such Force they've been moving
internal walls so these are really quite
volatile things when they go and you
need to be aware of that
welcome back now for many football fans
the next few days also are the real
business end of the season which will
decide promotional relegation Glory or
despair or one club that's earned an
early summer holidays Ipswich Town
promoted from League one to the
championship its first promotion in 23
years but while the players book their
Beach holidays behind the scenes it's
the busiest time of year with contracts
to be signed and big financial decisions
to be made for the next season we're
joining me now from Portman road is Mark
Ashton the chief executive of Ipswich
Town Mark welcome to you I've got to
start first of all there's an incredible
match in the league one last night
between Sheffield Wednesday and
Peterborough you must be delighted that
you're not in those playoffs
but you wouldn't believe
um I have to say I watched the game last
night Darren was someone I've known for
many many years and I was just so
pleased it wasn't us going through that
the anxiety and that pressure
um but what what a game what a great
advert for the sport as well for the
third tier of English football yeah so
it has been a fantastic season this year
I mean tell me all about summer for a
football chief executive I take it you
don't get any down time at all
no
um 38 days till the players returned for
pre-season uh and 78 days till we start
competitive league fixtures
um so myself and the staff uh behind the
scenes are very focused a number of
things to do players player trading
begins now as the transfer window starts
to open uh and then on top of that we
have all the infrastructure projects a
major investment here of uh two and a
half million pound into new pitch and
infrastructure projects in the stadium
and all the financial planning around
Financial fair play that comes with it
so very busy time for us
you took a big gamble uh appointing
Kieran McKenna as your manager he's
achieved his success in his first full
year are you going to be able to hang on
to him
yeah I would think so he seems very
happy
um I think the stability that we have as
a club the stability that the ownership
group brings here we're well financed
and we're moving forward in all
directions so I think Kieran understands
the journey he's on in his career I
think we're a perfect fit for each other
this is potentially a huge club with
huge opportunity and to have him leading
the team and taking us forward on the
pitch he's something we're very very
pleased with well you mentioned that
you're putting in a new pitch I mean
Portman Road already got some of the
biggest dependencies outside the Premier
League last year is there much that you
can do with the stadium in terms of
adding capacity
yeah I mean we're at 29 and a half
thousand capacity here with segregation
um when we joined the club you know
average attendancies were probably 13 14
000 in League one last season we were
averaging 27 000 in League one and we
were capping out at a lot of games
towards the end at 29 and a half
thousand just incredible before we were
promoted well we were still a ligue one
club we sold 22 sorry 21
000 season tickets for next season it's
just incredible
um the whole club has moved forward
um if you look at our retail for example
historically even in the Premier League
this football club had only turned over
about 1 million ish in in retail this
year will break through 4 million in
retail
um we averaged to sell around 12 000
shirts per season last season we have
sold 50 000. so financially and off the
pitch as well as on the pitch the club
is moving forward on a very steep upward
trajectory you sold 50 000 shirts that's
astonishing I mean is is that mainly
because you've got Ed Sheeran who of
course is a celebrity supporter he
designed one of the shirts I think
didn't he
yeah he did he got involved in the
blackout kit which was the third kit
um which was again was a really good
seller for us listen when you've got a
world Superstar who's a local man
supports the club supports his local
community sponsoring the shirt and is
part of the club uh moving forward it
can only help it certainly helps when
you launch your shirt on the first night
at Wembley Ed Sheeran rocks up in your
in your new home kit
um so he's fantastic
um a real big fan of the club and a huge
help to us but I think the whole club
has moved forward now it's such a pace
you know season tickets work in the
community
attendancies retail
um again as I said it's a very steep
upward trajectory that we're on
does that mean though that you can
immediately try and push for promotion
in the premiere for the to the Premier
League next year or is next year going
to be a season of consolidation
it'll be a season of progression for
sure
um again we're well backed
um like all the clubs there are
Financial fair play controls in place
profit and sustainability rules that we
have to adhere to
um but as we do we trade players
um you know we've we've bought well
we've bought young players in with uh
value the likes of Lee Davis Nathan
Broadhead Harry Clark from Arsenal Etc
Connor Chaplin who scored 29 goals last
season all young hungry players with
real value and whilst we've spent money
on those players what people forget is
we've also traded players out in the
background and if you look at our net
cash outflow for the for a three-year
period say last year this year and next
year and all the players we've brought
in all the players we've sold we're
literally Net Zero we will more or less
break even on player trading so while
people see what you buy they don't tend
to see sometimes what you're selling in
the background so we have a model and
we'll stick to the model I expect to to
attack the championship well and
continue to buy good players that give
Kieran McKenna the very best opportunity
to be competitive
now I hate to rake over old Coles but
before you joined Ipswich you were five
years at Bristol city where it's fair to
say some of the supporters think the
club could have done a bit better under
uh your stewardship what's the case for
the defense
um five years at Bristol amazing time
um you know we finished consistently
just outside the playoffs stadium was
completed training ground was built
carabao cup semi-final
um I have a really good relationship
with the ownership group there in fact
uh Ipswich get promoted and the very
first person that texts me and
congratulates me Steve lands down to
Bristol City owner so I think that tells
you about the relationship I still have
as a CEO look you take the bullets
sometimes things will go right some some
things will go wrong I have very fond
memories of Bristol city they're a
fantastic football club with Incredible
owners and I'm sure they'll be ultra
competitive next season and I look
forward to seeing the owners there for a
for a for a drink when we see them yeah
nice is your class guy Steve Mark all
the best dude good to see you this
morning thank you it's a pleasure thank
you for your time
these are the latest pictures that we've
all been waiting for this is the family
photo for the G7 right now this is in uh
it's uh kushima in Japan obviously the
main body of the meetings is being held
at the Oshima itself
[Music]
Schultz that we're looking at their
Rishi sunakers who live on the line from
the European uh Community Union
okay
not sure what that music is in the
background it's something traditionally
Japanese us bet
[Music]
here we go at least it stopped raining
for them it's been very miserable over
there the last uh 24 hours or so
now the rise of artificial intelligence
is like a freight train heading towards
the workforce that's what the chief
executive of one Energy company has told
Sky News it comes after BT announced
yesterday that around 10 000 jobs will
be replaced by Advanced AI in the next
seven years our business correspondent
Paul Kelso reports
I would definitely say that's something
that we should do when you pick up the
phone to accompany this is what you hope
you'll get a human to help sure I can
set that up for you over the phone but
send an email to octopus energy and the
answer might now start with artificial
intelligence it's answering 44 of
customer emails just seven weeks after
it was introduced it's read every email
we've ever sent to a customer it's uh
read every training manual we've ever
used with our team it's read every bit
of Regulation I mean it's read every bit
of the Arcane back end of energy
it kind of just knows it all right the
boss says AI won't cost jobs here but it
is a threat to workers in The Wider
economy around the world governments are
quite quickly beginning to think about
what they have to do here uh but we
haven't got time to wait and see because
uh you know look if a freight train is
coming at you you don't wait till you
feel it hit before moving out the way
that'll be too late
generative AI is changing the workplace
fast this London Law Firm has a bespoke
AI tool being used by three and a half
thousand lawyers in 43 countries just
three months after it was launched on an
individual basis it's a boring
productivity gain really it's an hour or
two week but when you multiply that by
three and a half thousand that is a big
deal for a business well before this
existed would that been a realistic
Target if you'd been asked to find
three and a half thousand dollars it's
impossible it was impossible to find
these productivity gains through a
single deployment of a system a year ago
we have done this job losses are
inevitable BT says it will replace 10
000 workers with Advanced AI by 2030 and
they won't be the only ones government
has no plans to legislate but unions say
rapid adoption of AI threatens workers
rights we say that at the very moment at
which regulation is most needed when the
Technologies are developing so rapidly
and the implications are so significant
instead of regulating the government is
putting forward flimsy invade proposals
that don't have any statutory footing
intelligence could trigger Industrial
Revolution for White Collar work with
the prospect of huge productivity gains
coming with warnings that millions of
jobs might cease to exist but the
technology is moving so fast we can't
know where that balance between promise
and pain will settle AI will create new
roles even as it consumes old jobs but
the speed of change is fast turning
science fiction into a fact of working
life Paul Kelso Sky News
well we're going to stay with AI now
earlier in the week we spoke with
luminance that's a company that uses
Advanced AI for the processing of
complex legal documents by corporate
customers but it's not the only player
in that particular field orbital witness
a technology platform using AI to make
buying commercial property simpler
claims it's already been used in 76 000
transactions today it's announced it's
raised seven and a half million pounds
in a series a funding ground joining me
now is its co-founder and chief
executive will pierce well what is this
value at now roughly so an orbital
witness we're really proud of the
progress we've been able to make we have
some very uh large customers we have
some of the largest law firms uh in in
the world over two and a half thousand
real estate lawyers using all between us
every single day our customers range
from ftse 100 listed retailers through
to large energy infrastructure companies
and we're really proud of this seven and
a half million pound series a race okay
and roughly how much does that value add
uh we're not going to disclose the the
precise value uh but uh we're really
proud of the the funding ground that
we've accomplished so what are you going
to put the proceeds towards sure so
we're doing a lot of a lot of job
creation we we have 45 people here in
our London office a lot of data
scientists a lot of software Engineers
we're roughly doubling that number in
the in the next 12 months we're
launching a new product you mentioned
our progress in commercial real estate
Ian we're now launching our technology
for for residential home buying so
working very closely with property
conveyancers uh in the in the home
buying home buying and selling process
and then thirdly we're spending a lot of
time in in new applications so we're
looking at how automated diligence
understanding legal issues straight away
in a transaction can help estate agents
can help mortgage lenders can help
anyone involved in in the world of
property it's all the processes involved
in buying commercial and residential
property replicable well there's a lot
of nuance uh the the that is specific to
commercial but the underlying documents
the underlying under understanding of
what a legal risk might be a particular
legal issue can be quite similar so to
give you a few examples in residential
conveyancing in home buying a risk might
be something very Financial it might be
an onerous service charge or ground rent
related to the flat you're buying it
also might be something quite emotional
it might be whether you're allowed to
have pets in the property but in
commercial it's a very sophisticated
industry real commercial real estate is
an exceptionally large asset class A lot
of the risks there are very Financial in
nature relating to security of rent
reviews and and Rental income streams
for example so with the residential
product will you be looking essentially
to save clients time or money or both
well both primarily but it goes further
than that I mean commercial real estate
is a very emotional Journey that people
go through buying a home is everyone's
highest value most stressful most
emotional purchase they'll make in their
life and there's a huge value
proposition in in residential just to
give people important information up
front so we're saving time we're saving
money for the for the residential
conveyancing solicitors and introducing
a lot of Peace of Mind introducing a lot
of certainty for everyone involved in
the property transaction by giving them
important information you heard that
report yesterday from BT 10 000 people
essentially going to lose their jobs due
to AI I mean are you looking to put
people out of work or is that just a
byproduct of what you do absolutely
absolutely not I mean there's a ton of
different jobs that will be created with
AI what we're really focused on at
orbital witness is how we can use
artificial intelligence to speed up the
property purchase process and to give
people important information about real
estate as I said at the beginning we
have a lot of really fantastic customers
that we're really proud of using using
orbital witness we've been used on about
one and a half percent of all UK
property transactions this year we spend
a lot of time with our customers
speaking about our vision and they love
the work that we're doing a lot of
lawyers didn't go to law school to read
Stacks and stacks of paper the average
commercial property deal can have about
1200 pages of document months to review
it's the same as War and Peace by
Tolstoy so a lot of these people are
really excited about the the work that
we're doing to to speed up their their
jobs you've mentioned the the uh the
solicitors side of the process I mean
one of the other real sort of things
that throws grain into the into the
wheel of a house purchases local
Authority searches yeah yeah is this
something that you're going to be able
to help tackle well I mean to some
degree yes there's always going to be a
kind of a problem of getting hold of
information so local Authority searches
rely on a local Authority having
information that they can distribute to
the to the property uh to the property
purchases a lot of what we're doing is
then analyzing that local Authority
search using artificial intelligence as
well as lots of other documents from the
land registry or planning permissions
for example so the review of the
particular search that you're talking
about uh Ian is is where is where
orbital witness will be used rather than
the acquisition of that of of that
information in the first place all right
and how is the company born we have a a
pretty fun origin story myself my
co-founder Ed started life in the space
industry right we were spending uh time
as as young entrepreneurs in the space
industry which is where the name orbital
comes from as part of that Journey we
found ourselves in the London offices of
a large London law firm and to be frank
we were shocked with the stacks of paper
uh sitting on people's desks the amount
of hours that some of these lawyers were
working to uh the delays in the
transaction that the client just wanted
to proceed with the deal so we're
Outsiders to the real estate industry uh
and uh yeah we're we're really excited
about the the problem that we're solving
all right well good to see you this
morning thank you very much
bit of a breaking news that we can bring
you which is that Timothy Schofield he
is the brother of the TV star Philip
Schofield he has been jailed at Bristol
Crown Court for 12 years after being
convicted of 11 sexual offenses
involving a child will no doubt have
more on that throughout the morning here
on Sky News in the meantime some more
breaking news for you uh president
zielinski has arrived in Jeddah to
attend the Arab League that is a report
from al-hadath TV in Dubai president
zielinski arrived in uh on in Jeddah on
Friday for the Arab League Summit
al-harath TV is actually owned by the
Saudi government he arrived on a French
government plane and this of course
comes amid reports that he is going to
attend the G7 leader Summit in the city
of Hiroshima this weekend so lots of
interesting developments there obviously
he is going to be pushing for uh the U.S
in particular to start supplying F6 team
fighter jets to Ukraine I'm sure we'll
have more on that throughout the weekend
here on Sky News but still to come on
inking live we're going to be having a
look at what's in today's business Pages
next with Neil Collins from the evening
standard don't go away
foreign
[Music]
increase on the same period last year
Well since in that two-month period we
had further fire deaths and further fire
injuries all Associated to e-bikes and
e-scooters talk to me about these
pictures what what
here well you can see the picture here
so the key point I'd like your viewers
to take away here is you've gone from a
normal morning in a kitchen with
somebody charging a re-scooter to an
unsurvivable environment in a little
under 12 seconds that what looks like
smoke is a totally toxic Vapor Cloud it
has just about every nasty gas hydrogen
cyanide in it you can you can think of
really toxic and then you've got to
Total flashover conditions those Flames
are over a thousand degrees and it
explodes and puts particles all over
your your room and the other thing
you're not quite seeing on that footage
is that that that scooter has been
charged in a communal kitchen next to
the communal Escape Route for a number
of bed sits so that totally compromised
the Escape Route nobody's getting past
that ideally charge it outside charge it
outside or in a garage it can and of
course they're quite a capital
investment you know these scooters are
probably one and a half thousand to two
thousand pounds e-bikes are over two
thousand pounds so you know a lot of
people won't want to charge outside
because it's quite an investment if you
are having to charge it inside that is
not ideal I need to be clear about that
if you are having to charge it outside
don't compromise your Escape Route you
know have it somewhere where if it does
fail you can close the door and leave
immediately get your family you know
alert your neighbors get out call us out
and stay out we've had examples okay uh
you know around the corner in southwark
a foldable e-bike uh the the occupants
heard a hiss and a bang and it blew the
bedroom door off and they they explode
with such Force they've been moving
internal walls so these are really quite
volatile things when they go and you
need to be aware of that
[Music]
thank you tap into the latest news and
insight invest in your future Sky News
Financial reports sponsored by
interactive investor
[Music]
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
to another look at this morning's
business pages and the financial time
splashes its print edition with news of
the BT job cuts on which we reported
this time yesterday the paper's Lex
column says it sounds a big number but
points out that most job losses will
result from the completion of BT's
rollout of fiber Broadband the Ft also
carries an interview with the
influential investor Carl Icahn in which
he admits he was wrong to make a huge
bet in 2017 on crashes in a number of
financial markets the BET cost his group
nine billion dollars over roughly six
years the times leads its business pages
with the UK government semiconductor
strategy announcement but it also
reports that the fintech company
revolutes attempts to secure a
long-awaited banking license is in doubt
after it emerged that the bank of
England is minded to reject its
application well that story makes the
lead in the business pages of the Daily
Telegraph which also reports on an
assessment yesterday from the office for
Budget responsibility that the age of
massive house price increases may be
nearing and end the obr says this is due
to slowing pump population growth and
interest rate Rises well joining me are
several on a Friday morning is the
financial markets commentator and
evening standard Economist Neil Collins
Neil good to see you this morning we'll
obviously one of the big stories this
week was uh stalantis calling for the uh
deal between the UK and the EU of
post-brexit to be renegotiated what did
you make of that
yeah the trouble with the motor business
is that it it's full of emotion uh and
because it is so uh obviously uh in
people's minds people know what a car is
they like to know where they're built uh
and where they're built is extremely
important in terms of the value chain
um it's almost impossible for
governments to stay out of this
um indeed following stalantis's uh uh
comments and and requests demands call
them what you will for financial
assistance we've now got a story today
that Tata the owner of
um
Land Rover and jaguar are asking for up
to 500 million in assistance to build a
battery plant in the UK rather than in
Spain and this is sort of it's pretty
Grim really because there is something
approaching a sort of a subsidy scramble
here not just in the UK but Across the
Western World with the understanding
that because batteries are so heavy
they're very difficult to uh to
transport
so they really do need to be where the
cars are being built
and so both the US and the EU have
committed themselves to very substantial
subsidies
um I fear though that this is not a very
uh encouraging raised to the bottom
because the substances are all very well
but the underlying problem that the
European and to a lesser extent the US
car industry has is the cost of energy
Europe including the UK is committed to
essentially being high energy cost
economies the better or worse this is
the result of the greenery
um whereas in China they have understood
the need to uh
keep energy costs low and I am afraid
that they are a long way ahead in the
development of cheap electric cars
because essentially they are
guaranteeing cheap cheap energy and that
is something which
no number of government subsidies here
and in Europe are going to overcome so I
fear that we are going to see the
eclipse of the UK Mass Market
manufacturing industry and in future the
cars on UK Road the electric cars anyway
on the UK roads will come from China
indeed uh well you've been talking now
we've been showing some pictures of the
G7 leaders
um the G7 obviously it's Heyday was in
the 1980s when those economies accounted
for getting on for 70 Global GDP is it
still relevant these days do you think
well it's not irrelevant but um there's
no question that the economic center of
gravity of the world has moved to the
East and particularly the Far East uh
they that is where the world's fastest
growing economies are that is where
there's the most dynamism uh there's
often the feeling that in the west we're
more concerned about trying to preserve
what we've got rather than trying to
look ahead and and grow the economy and
stay in our position as one of the uh
emerging or the most emerged countries I
think this is not confined to Britain I
think it's across Western Europe to a
greater extent so there's a limit to
what we can do to fight that so is the
GCM G7 still relevant yes of course it
is but it's nowhere near as dominant as
it used to be
yes and uh that ties in very neatly with
the comment you were making on Chinese
car manufacturing just now Neil got to
leave it there good to see you this this
morning thank you
well just before I go reminder to check
out the inking live podcast you can find
that by scanning the QR code on your
screen right now it's available wherever
you get your podcasts including the Sky
News app Apple and Google podcast and
Spotify and you can also uh find plenty
more business news on our digital
platforms right now I did a piece
yesterday on the water UK announcement
and why it's taken so long for the
industry to get around to tackling these
sewage spills do have a look at that if
you can well that's it from me for this
week what a week it's been for the
Japanese stock market in particular I'm
back on Monday morning at 10 o'clock
hope very much to see you then in the
meantime do stay tuned after this short
break it's Sam Washington with all the
latest from the G7 have a good weekend
cheers
foreign
[Music]